على الارض بعد معارك عنيفه تمكنت القوات
الروسيه عمليا من تطويق مدينه باخمود التي
يجرى فيها القتال الان من اجل السيطره
عليها من ثلاثه محاور وتعمل على طرد
القوات الاوكرانيه من مواقعها هذا واكدت
سلطات المحليه في جمهوريات لوجاست الشعبيه
ان القوه الروسيه تحاول ان تقدم الى مدينه
ساسوفيار الخاضعه لسيطره اكياس والتي يتم
عبرها لدار وباخمود بشكل مكثف القوات
الروسيه تعمل ايضا بشكل منها شيء على قطع
الخطوط الامداد والاتصال على القوات
الاوكرانيه في باخمود وحصرها بين فكي
كماشه في حين تدور المعارك في ضحايا وضاحي
المدينه وتحديدا في تلك الاحياء التي
سيطرت عليها الوحدات الاوكرانيه مؤخرا
موافقه طبعا السلطات المحليه